Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
By the way, do you guys know the word, "phone tag"?
Phone tag is the word we use when you call somebody and you can't reach them.
And then, they call you back, and they can't reach you.
And in the end, you talk to them and say,...
..."Oh, sorry. We were playing phone tag."
It's a very useful word to know.
Okay. Today's topic...
How may I assist your call.
Hello, this is Seita from AERA English TV. How may I assist your call?
And one more.
This is he.
Yes, this is he.
This is she.
Hello, is Seita there?
Yes, this is he.
Okay, let's practice.
How may I assist your call?
Please repeat.
Good.
Next.
Yes, this is he.
Good.
Okay. Learn Business English like this and telephone will be very easy.
Okay. That's it for today.
And next week, there'll be more information to help you become the native maestro.
Bye-bye.